when a relationship is over you know
it's the equivalent of milk being
expired do you put the milk back in the
fridge and expect it to be fresh again
or do you just toss it and move the [ __ ]
on and buy new milk
what the [ __ ] is going on
i
like to party jesus
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone we just become best friends
[Music]
we had her on once and that was not
enough for us she is the creator of
let's [ __ ] date the self-proclaimed
queen of confidence was just on tour we
have been dying to see it by the way so
come to la and i can't wait to hear what
she has coming next we love this girl
and so will you this is serena [ __ ]
kerrigan studio audience round of
applause
okay wait look what can i just say by
the way um i carry your card game
everywhere i go you're kidding literally
i actually didn't even realize i had in
my bag when i brought it here oh yeah i
was like wait i should play this no but
i it works both it is great i have like
the deluxe version and then the regular
version
and i want to get into the card game but
i would just like to mention
if you're an og listener of the unwax
podcast serena was on episode two
the second episode that we'd ever put
out ever and it still is one of my
favorite episodes no seriously you guys
are so sweet we're not just saying that
you gave such good advice and before you
were a confidence coach yeah that was so
long ago literally everything's changed
so much i mean like you're still the
queen of confidence but you're not the
coach anymore but you kind of you kind
of coach in a way with like your tick
tock videos right yes yes like how did
you even get in are you still
trying to coach people well i mean i
just felt like i was doing it on zoom
because i just quit my job right
pre-pandy like yeah yeah
and you know i was doing the coaching on
zoom but then like every single person
was asking me the same question they
were upset about the same things and i
was like what if i could just like sum
it up in a video make it accessible for
everyone you know i'm not trying to
gatekeep confidence right right um so
that has like worked in my favor but
yeah that's so crazy i mean you guys
were so fun i feel like when i walked in
here i was like i feel like i know
it's you're like we're meeting in person
it's like we've been following each
other for so long yeah we've been
talking for so long and i don't know if
you're dming messaging i was like this
is really weird that this is the first
time in person i know i feel like we've
known each other for years yeah well
because
but i would love to know like because
when you first came on you didn't have
your card game like let's [ __ ] date
wasn't exactly
the business that it is today so
how did you make those like steps and
you pivoted totally and now you're like
a full-blown business woman on tour i
mean you have so many things coming out
ceo bad [ __ ] yeah
well i think it was about really like
deciding like what do i want and like
being vocal about it i feel like we're
so
women especially like you know we're
always told to like you know
not be
outward about the things that we want in
life you know because it might come off
cocky or arrogant or you know people
will roll our eyes or it's like cringy
like you know but i really don't care
because it's not their life right yeah
so i was very much like i you know the
card game was just like i started that
dating show during the pandemic lol date
of 50 guys
loved it crazy i would never do that
again
i think i remember the fire fighter that
was like
the one that you guys if you guys don't
know what we're talking about serena
went on live stream dates with these
guys and people were commenting and then
you would let the viewers like yeah
and that was really fun like that was
like a really good moment like of like
you know learning about myself and
dating which we will definitely discuss
because i want to know what's going on
are any of those guys like creeping back
today and still like i'm friends with
some of them and i think that that was a
good lesson where it's like go on a lot
of dates like even if you're not gonna
you don't find your person in you know a
slew of dates like you're gonna learn
something about yourself you also could
like make friends you know when i was
still friends with people from the show
i meet a lot of girlfriends from the
show too that were like on the after
show right right and then i create the
card game because i wanted to have
something that you know you could keep
in your back pocket like you carry
around literally everywhere i love it if
you guys know what the card game is by
the way it's basically a game that is
getting to know someone there's first
second third base oh she
has this is what a true entrepreneur
does yeah that's right
you guys need this when i say it
literally goes from like
like subtle to spicy and also dares all
of his stuff and it's just like you get
to know the person on every level
sexually intellectually yeah physically
it is a second base third hashtag
hashtag sponsor thank you so much
i'm like a huge advocate i loved it so
i'm not gonna like not promote something
but it was so smart because i think a
lot of people liked those games like the
we're not very strangers right those
things like that but this is just
another extra umph yeah yeah
that works though like what do you mean
by works okay
elaborates the scene
works
when i was seeing this guy
he had a problem with opening up about
like what he likes even just his
personality it was so hard to get any
answers out of him so one day i
surprised him i brought your card game
to dinner and i sat him down and i was
like
we're at first base here we go and he
was like what the hell is this i'm like
you're gonna play along we ended up
sitting at dinner for four hours and we
just kept talking and talking and we got
to know each other on like an
emotionally deep level a sexually deep
level just being compatible in ways that
we would have never figured out had it
not been for this card game right i mean
genius how did you come up with the idea
because [ __ ] i was dating so much
during the pandemic that i was like i
needed to start writing questions that
were like gonna be entertaining for the
audience and not just like getting to
know the person right how are you dating
so much during a pandemic like were you
on an app like how were you meeting
these guys it was through my instagram
live dating show let's [ __ ] date
that's it like i wasn't going on the
apps that was it because i also wanted
to show the audience like hey or
everyone like you can like dating on
facetime like can be 100 a thing oh yeah
it's not cringy because at the end of
the day what are you doing you're you're
you're speaking yeah yeah all about
communication yeah yeah so i kind of
created the game to help people like if
they were facetiming someone like how
could it be fun you know right
right right and then there's obviously
other iterations of the game like sexier
versions yeah um but it's been really
it's been awesome like i love when i'm
like in the airport and a girl runs up
to me she's like look what i brought
with me on my trip oh are you kidding me
you have this moment yeah like die to
see those moments no it was like so good
that's so much fun and what is so for
people that don't know how would you
describe your brand let's [ __ ] date
let's [ __ ] date yeah i think it's an
extension of the sfk brand which is
queen of confidence like being the main
[ __ ] character doing it for the
plot yeah just really like realizing
that like you live once and you know
life is just too short to not yeah
absolutely obsessed with yourself i love
doing for the plot he loves you i love
it what that means yeah people so do
over the plot is was an extension of
like being the main character which i'm
like everyone is like you just have to
access that part of it and it was really
like doing things that make you happy
for the story just like kind of like
i think that people just get pretty
upset about when things don't go their
way or they are embarrassed if they like
got too drunk one night and i'm just
like it's for the plot like it's for the
plot of your life think about any main
character in any movie they don't it's
not all perfect and like daisies or
what's the phrase
sunshine
roses
is whatever it's just
a flower
daffodils exactly like it's not just
like that right like we're all gonna
have ups and downs
we get rejected or redirects us to
something better yeah yeah and so it's
about like being like [ __ ] it like i'm
doing it for the plot like i'm either
gonna like travel start something new
play the card game with a guy like i
never play my card game with a guy
because it's like because i'm on the
[ __ ] box oh my god that's true
also you did send us you did send us um
a few like boxes care packages of
goodies and her face was on
a condom oh yeah i should i should have
brought you more
now you're single
by the way i like don't even want to use
it because it's just so cute
i'm like i want to keep it except one
night i did and he was like what is that
it's me wait did he hate it though cause
i'm like that's kind of badass i mean
yeah i probably hated it because it was
a condom but yes
he loved it obvi
but i like i i sometimes like i'm
reluctant to play but i did go to vegas
this weekend did you forget um like for
work it was like kind of like a trip
with like a lot of creators and what the
videographer was there to like take our
content and like we ended up like
falling in love and like we played the
game and the game was so good because
there's questions in it that you might
not want to like ask right like exactly
you know how would you describe our
relationship in three words i said that
to me and i was like what is he gonna
say we literally just met what did he
say he was just like connected
spontaneous and hopeful which is so cute
he's like tequila sls pool party
wait tal group that's the best answer
but it worked yeah yeah i just try to
hide my face because it's on all the
cards but i did it i was just like
like just go with the problem
do you guys ever get intimidated because
not only are you just such a boss woman
but you're so confident in yourself
because
confidence i think definitely
intimidates a lot of men right and this
is like something that comes up a lot
i've been working on in therapy because
i sometimes i'm like do i diminish like
my accomplishments right or like do i
like try to not talk about my career too
much you know there's things that i want
like i try to not do to not like
emasculate a
a straight man in this case and i
then i was like you know what [ __ ] it
like
if i'm too much literally go find less
like yeah it's just not my pro like
that's not my problem that's true like
and i realized i'm like why am i like
for example like
not vegas guy because he's taught me
full sfk like full personal everything
i think there's such a power to giving
yourself a name when you're having that
full send moment because it's like we
have i call myself bambi i love it you
say i'm tina oh like but lovely
because i'm like if i'm going to act a
certain way it's not normally how i am
but it also gives me excuses to go this
isn't me it's for the podcast like
that's your thoughts i know i'm like
drama i'm like 16 i want to just cause
chaos this weekend i'm obsessed yeah i
let us ban because that's such like
innocent name but it's like but she also
falls like her ankles stop working when
she drinks
bambi has like very weak ankles when she
drinks tequila she falls alone and tina
where did tina come from
um tina belcher because i kind of danced
like her from bob's burgers
not all of the specific visas i know
i know well yours is a little sad but
yeah it's not cute that's definitely for
sure not cute not cute but when i like
you know the biggest guy was a full
scent sfk energy whatever and yeah also
had an alter ego by the way i forget
what its name was but like same thing so
he got it oh perfect but typically like
with other guys sometimes i'm like
do i hide my instagram story from them
like i've thought about interest and
i've done it and then i'm like oh like
it makes me feel like if they can't
separate that this is my job and like
there's that persona on the internet and
all of us are playing a person on the
internet
right highlight real 100
so if he can't realize that there's a
difference between the two it's not like
i'm behind him goldman sachs like
watching him on excel doing spreadsheets
about investment banking right like he's
literally getting full access to my job
and i think that you know before i was
trying to hide it and i think ultimately
you need to be on a percent yourself and
sfk serena those are like tina bambi
that's who you are and if you don't you
can't handle bambi and tina and that's
okay you can't [ __ ] handle this you
can't that takes a level of security
with yourself that i think a lot of
people don't have so say if like what if
someone is just a people pleaser or
they're wanting validation from other
people it's hard to be your authentic
self because you're just trying to make
sure that you don't step on any toes
make sure everyone likes me make sure
i'm not acting too crazy like what would
you give right you know advice to
someone that is thinking that i mean
honestly like
you're never gonna be happy because like
not everyone's gonna like think about
you don't like everyone there are people
you met you that just you don't like
they rub you the wrong way whatever
right you're not gonna like everyone not
everyone's gonna like you and that's
totally fine because you know
there's gonna be enough people around
you that support you and love you and
will give you constructive feedback but
like it's just a no-win game i used to
be like that i wanted everyone i'm an
only child even though now i have three
sisters but oh of course well we're all
with the first letter
so it fits right
right in but you know like i was an only
child i always wanted to be liked like i
wanted friends and i wanted to feel that
secureness and like feeling like i just
had a community or a family or whatever
right and then it just like i spent a
lot of my childhood crying like a lot
like a lot because because it's like if
someone didn't like me i couldn't handle
it i know it's like you'll know
i feel that all the time i feel
um an extreme like it eats me alive even
if it's my sister or someone i just met
i cannot handle the idea of someone not
like okay but let's pause for a second
do they actually not like you are you
projecting your anxiety onto them
definitely option b okay cool so the
reason and we have to go back you know
we talked about this on the first part
but you have to go back to you and
building a relationship with yourself
yeah like when i came in you hyped me up
you know like you obviously give so much
love to your sister and everyone around
you you need to give that same love to
yourself
like amen straight up like sorry you
know business no i said
dude
no but i think that you
you we don't do that it's so weird right
we're not taught that yeah
like when if i were to ask you guys like
how do you just like how do you
demonstrate love to someone like answer
the question like how do you demonstrate
love i would do it by i like to give
advice or i like to just console them if
they're ever down like that's my kind of
thing is nurturing someone okay i like
to show in in ways like oh i'll do this
for you i'll help you with that like run
errands for them great yeah okay so
those are i hear talking communication
and acts of service or action
yeah so if we're supposed to love
ourselves why don't we do that to
ourselves right like why don't we give
advice to ourselves when we're down why
don't we go you know do things for
ourselves when we're feeling sad right
it's almost like we're out of the
equation but if you think about what
love is and how to express it
those are the two things that we know
how to do for everyone else but we don't
do it ourselves it's so crazy no it's
crazy but then you realize when you find
someone whether it's a guy or your
friendship because i know even with
girls when you are doing a lot of things
you feel almost and do you ever feel
like sometimes when you're succeeding or
you're doing something good you have
friends where you don't want to tell
that to because you're like i feel like
they're going to judge me or they're not
going to be that excited are they really
your friends exactly they're not but
when you actually shift that and you
choose people that are wanting to be
your support team and they want to be
proud of you and they are hyping you up
i feel like that self love with you
actually gets even bigger just because
you don't have to worry and then i'll
show you you don't want to rely on
someone else to give you that self love
it starts with yourself that's true you
said that we're just not taught how to
do it exactly so you said that you you
cried a lot as a child and
can relate um
but you now have this incredible
confidence and security with yourself at
what point in your life did that sort of
shift for you i think it's when i
started calling myself sfk serena ethan
carrigan what age was that do you think
i was when i was 18.
yeah like when i got to college was an
adult she became a messenger baby i
couldn't drink yet but i did because i'm
good
no but i like i got to college and i was
like oh
i was really like i got that social
anxiety of like what if people don't
like me what if um
like i remember i was at the bar and
like all the guys it felt like they were
like looking past me right i felt
invisible
and i was like i'm gonna have a really
horrendous four years
of my life here if i can't like feel
that validation from within because then
i'm gonna be like that guy didn't talk
to me oh my god like these girls don't
want to be friends over like so i was
like what would like i literally said
what would sfk do like and i just kept
saying to myself like you're serena
[ __ ] kerrigan like you go up to that
guy like you right but that's what that
is i mean that's what we do to each
other no it's true now i actually saw
your wake up with elle and i loved it
and i actually really really really
loved when you were talking to yourself
like oh i'm gonna look at myself in the
mirror and not think that that person is
me that's very helpful and i loved that
way to
it was i mean you can explain it since
wait i love that you tuned in you're so
no i'm so proud of you because it's like
really i think you do every time every
year
i mean just because we've seen you from
what it was before to now and you are as
hard working as you actually you'd say
that you are hard work and it's so true
because some people are like no it's
yeah it's incredible the jump you've
made in literally too short it's crazy
and during a pandemic i mean like but no
with the wake up without i mean i i mean
she can explain it better but she was
saying that she looked at herself in the
mirror and she was like okay i'm gonna
tell myself all these positive things
like you're beautiful go [ __ ] kill it
you're awesome blah blah blah but don't
look at yourself thinking that's you
pretend you're talking to someone else
it's like another person do you know
what i'm saying so you disassociate from
you kind of cringing at yourself going
like oh i'm talking to myself in the
mirror no no you're talking to a person
nailed it and it's so helpful that like
almost it's like
terrible phrase social distancing but
it's like that distancing of self that's
why it's like if you were just sitting
here in a room without a mirror or
anything being like you're amazing
i'd be like that's hard to do right like
that's weird but you know how to have a
conversation and you can definitely have
a conversation with another person yeah
so by looking in the mirror it's like
this yes it's you but it's like it's
that kind of
disassociating that really makes it
easier so what is what does the
conversation with yourself look like in
the mirror i literally did this last
time on my instagram story but i
basically was just saying like you know
i i just said i love you i'm proud of
you
i
you know you don't always have the
answers but you really like think about
it critically and you see other points
of view
and have a great [ __ ] night like
tomorrow you have a wake-up call [ __ ]
you know what i mean like that's what it
is but like what would you say you know
to your best friend it's so true when
girls ask me advice on instagram
sometimes literally because i just am
too [ __ ] busy and also just to
see it as a kind of a test yeah they'll
send me legitimately a paragraph
paragraph a whole story and i just go i
literally respond i said what would you
say to me if i copied and pasted this
entire message what advice would you
give to me and then it's all there like
all the time you have the right and it's
the same thing as the mirror it's like
the second it's not them it's they can
see clearly it's crazy because they
forget that you can give the same advice
to yourself
are you done chewing sophia it's not gum
this is an asmr what are you chewing i'm
chewing
prima gummy vitamins because i'm
stressed out the fact that we have a
bunch of guests today and we have to
shoot more tonight no it's a lot like
wait how do they taste they're so good
no actually they're so good they kind of
taste like a little bit of a starburst
consistency well let's see it says chill
out relax and unwind take the edge off
anytime anywhere
yeah oh good sounds good to me oh and i
like anything
that can make me calm
taste sweet especially after i eat
dinner and stuff i need something like
nice yeah that little sugar cake yeah
especially if you go to bed you want to
feel calm it's kind of a good well it's
kind of a perfect balance because you're
getting that little sugar fix yeah and
you're getting relaxed before bed it's
kind of the perfect thing and you guys
i'm really not kidding when i say
they're actually really good and i'm
excited to see how i feel because i am
pretty stressed out today and that's why
at least 75-90 doctor visits are from
stress related issues which is wild
that's an insane number
well
sophie and i can obviously attest to
this many of us are operating on
survival mode we expect our skin our
bodies our minds to thrive especially
being on camera when honestly we're
running on empty all the time yeah
that's why we use prima because it's
california based and it is a new
purpose-led cbd
brand that is just targeted to make you
feel your calmest and best they are
dedicated to help you rise above modern
day stress so every day is a little bit
better with our doctor formulated
clinically validated high performance
products for the skin body and mind i
want to keep eating these gummies but if
you guys don't know where to start other
than the gummies which i highly
recommend you can always take their
daily capsules that just help you be
calm throughout the day or if you want
i'm trying to find the name of it it's
called sleep tight because i know that
she struggles with this but we are
insomniacs we don't sleep so this has
been amazing to our sleep this is
actually the only thing that has worked
and i've tried nearly every product on
the market in prima's sleep cbd
chef's kiss so i hope you guys are
already convinced enough about this and
so lucky for us prima is offering our
listeners an exclusive limited time 20
off offer with the code unwaxed so
please you guys do yourself a favor and
get calm by going to prima.co and using
the code word unwax to get that 20
off limited time offer
guys come on if i'm saying that this
tastes like a starburst
and you're gonna be calm get the relief
you guys deserve and you can feel better
every day sounds pretty good to me
you know what actually i don't know if
you you're open to talking about therapy
right of course i love the fact that
you're so vocal about being so confident
but you're also so vocal about going to
therapy so what is it because you're
trying to also how why do you go to
therapy when you
do you know how that's because i think
that confidence is being your best
friend yeah that's what it is do you
always like your best friend
no no right like she can be [ __ ]
annoying you don't like her outfit
sometimes she's like right she takes a
bad picture of you right like but you
always will love her you know what i
mean and maybe a better use of an
example is his sister i never had a
sister now i have three but like i
didn't so
best friend was a you know that it was a
term that i related to but
you know it's also confidence is
celebrating what you don't know what you
could work on because i think a lot of
people that are insecure sometimes
overcompensating like i'm perfect i'm
what they're cocky yeah yeah being like
you know what i don't really know about
this i don't know if i'm handling it in
the best way do you have feedback that's
confidence realizing that like you have
things to work on and that's not doesn't
mean you're like the worst person ever
right no it's so true so therapy i mean
i think like it's it's
therapy is something i've been doing
since i was seven years old like it was
just like very normalized in my
household that's really good it's so it
really is yeah
you know obviously it's a privilege and
some people can't afford it and i wish
i think it's getting better now more
normalized and there's more like
available programs out there but
it's something that i'm like i can't
believe people don't do because it's
like yes yeah but you know what it is
you don't have to hit rock bottom and go
oh i know and it but the fact that
people still think things yeah the
therapy is like the last case scenario
the last resort like the last hail mary
when i'm 45 minutes to talk about
yourself about yourself
oh my god if i convinced my and my
friends about myself for hours i'd be
like i know i have so much on exactly
exactly followers question they're like
okay well serena has it all figured out
she has confidence like why would she
need to go to therapy i don't think
they've ever brought that up because
it's like therapy i mean a lot of what
therapy is is realizing how your
upbringing in your childhood has really
impacted behaviors in your life right
like the guy rejects me and i start
crying and spiraling whatever like maybe
it has to do with something
growing up where like i saw that action
happening taking place in front of me
and i internalized it whatever right
it's really like almost like we're all
puzzles and it's like why are we built
this way i think that's what therapy is
so having
i love it i'm new at it so yeah really
yay really amazing for me
you
know so much and like you're literally
an encyclopedia of just like knowledge
about self-love and confidence did you
learn a little bit of that from therapy
or did you have sort of like a mentor
that you looked up to i feel like you're
just very self-aware yeah like was there
yeah was there someone that you're like
i love what they're preaching and
someone you followed for a long time
yeah my mom oh like literally
a bad [ __ ]
we love her no she when i was like eight
years old she hung up we shared a
bathroom growing up okay which now i'm
like literally how but whatever
it works and we shared a shower and she
hung up in the shower this shower
curtain which i kind of want to recreate
for like my brand at some point but who
has shower curtains like no one has yeah
really yeah but maybe kids
um but it said like naked and happy i
love me me me like and it was like that
kind of subliminal messaging that i
thought like when i was growing i didn't
think of anything of it but i think that
that was like the kind of household i
grew up in was like right was confident
was loving yourself and like
and i think that that was you know she
you know when you go through puberty
when the boys don't like i'm so scared
like i have therapy after this podcast
yesterday i went on a date like i'm
always like
yeah it's like not even about confidence
it's like i'm going to therapy because i
want to talk about this date i went on
versus the guy that i met in vegas
because it's
a little cool that i'm just spilling the
tea here yeah because i was just like
you know they offered they were pros and
cons to both right and why am i being
drawn towards someone versus the other
right very curious
are you curious about the fact that
you're why you so interested in this
person one you should be interested in
the nut that i don't like to say should
but yeah like
one of the surprises available in a
different state and one of them's in new
york well why am i leaning towards it
because we like the unavailable the bad
guy the like you know the or is it that
maybe the other guy just wasn't a [ __ ]
yes
exactly no sometimes you don't even
realize the type that you like wait wait
i want to hear about your date yes yes
yes
let's talk about dating because
currently you guys were in new york and
you would think the dating scene would
be easy but according to you it's pretty
difficult in new york i think it's
difficult everywhere i think that after
the pandemic yeah when everything was
about virtual dating there was a shift
like before i dated before the pandemic
i felt like
you would be like are you on the apps
now it's like if you're single you're on
the apps oh 100 yeah
right like like you like like literally
how else do you mean no but people
forget how to socialize or people that's
great literally
everyone has to re-learn how to talk
fully and i also think that guys are
very intimidated to approach women now
in bars or out because the app is so
safe for them
it's a guarantee it's going like okay
she for sure wants to talk people kind
of use these dating apps as a security
blanket fully like because think about
it like you don't know if you get
rejected like that's so epic for a guy i
feel like a guy could easily reverse
this dialogue and say well why don't you
come up to us and say something but then
they i feel like girls have the sort of
stigma that oh you're so aggressive or
you're too sexual or like you you know
anyway that's interesting because i feel
like if a guy does approach me at a bar
i'm kind of like you actually [ __ ] up
so yeah it's a double standard sorry
sucks for you guys so
every time a guy approached me if it
wasn't someone i was like staring at and
we were making you know what i'm saying
but i was totally fine i mean i don't
know if you guys were like this but i
don't like going up to someone and
saying like hey what's up and it's
totally normal do you ever go up to
people when you're interested in those
like you know i'm too yeah i [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of them and then they come over
oh sorry
actually no wait guys actually wait
yes yes i understand smart i think it's
all about context like i think when i
was in vegas i just went on trip and the
videographer on that trip was
very like gorgeous and like i wasn't
really talking to any of the girls and i
was just like hot like a group of 10
girls right yeah so like talking to no
one and then everyone was like he's so
hot and i was like yeah damn and then i
was like why isn't he coming over and i
was like he must have a girlfriend right
yeah right of course and then
finally like it was just too many hours
together and i literally was just like
i'm i'm like hey come over like like
what's your story and he sat down and we
chatted forever and then like boom like
it went from there yeah but it's like so
that was the time i did approach but it
was like within the context of work
versus like being at like a
bar
downstairs in the basement where i was
like
it's basically you want to meet your
like where did you meet your oh no i met
him on a double date but like that's the
thing is i
no it's fine technically i i actually
prefer like i liked that we met like in
that kind of organic way because i
wouldn't want to meet him in like the
basement of acme i'm sorry like that's a
fun place but you can't see anybody or
100 and my persona in a way is a totally
different mindset than how i am when i'm
sober do you know which is good which is
great because i think bambi would
probably
yeah but you know what i'm saying so i
feel like it's fully and i think that a
lot of women are like where do i meet
guys irl like where do i meet the women
and i'm like well you know what i
started to do i started to visualize
like where would i want my future person
to be right library downstairs you want
them at the library she does for sure
but you're not funny but actually though
like because i don't know it's like on a
saturday day yeah throughout the library
that's [ __ ] weird that's weird i
don't like you i love that like you know
i was thinking like i would like to meet
them maybe in a work environment so they
understand like my career and my vibe
right yes you want someone that is maybe
not even in the same field but still has
the drive
how did you meet this guy that you went
on a date with last night so i met him
on hinge how do you do you like hinge do
you like him do you have a good profile
what what of course i have a great
product what's your song please
oh right
um
difficult because there's not many
prompts like you can't there's nothing
to like
banter off of six photos
do you do the talking part for hinge
and it's like the cringiest thing ever
that guys do it they're like i'm like
literally why are you speaking and i
hate when a guy sends a voice note we're
like well i think it's actually honestly
the best way to just kind of like power
through it like you know who's the freak
i feel like only people that hate voice
notes like everyone else likes them i do
like boys but i just well they're it's
annoying it is annoying it's it depends
on the person that's sending the voice
100 and like sometimes it's just better
to get it out yeah yeah yeah maybe i
like giving them not receiving
i'm a giver a vision
so this guy we matched and then i kind
of like you know it's difficult there's
so many options obviously everyone
swipes right on me obviously obviously
if you're not saying it you're showing
up like this happening obviously yeah
hinge this is how i would love
to show up on a date like this like baby
no
definitely not but honestly i heard
wearing a bold color on a first date is
the move it is i never do that because
i'm you know like a new yorker and i'm
always black but yeah for you guys this
isn't our first date though though it's
not for sitting today exactly
it's going great so you know i i
match with a lot of guys we there's fun
banter there's some but like it's very
difficult to get on the date right yeah
like to really like go
you know and i felt like it was funny
enough that i was like okay we'll like
we'll be able to have a good
conversation what made you hesitate
because i think that i was in a place of
my life and like i i kind of ghosted him
for like two months on the app like i
was like hey like resurrected [ __ ] but
like right like i think i was an
important life a couple months ago where
i kept telling myself like it's not the
right time like your career
right and i was like but people have
great careers and partners and i think
like thank you yeah people think you
have to pick one what's so funny is that
was my biggest fear in life was that i
always have to choose one or the other
i'm like i either can be in a great
relationship and like have my kids and
be married and whatever and have like a
lot of daddy thing but then also like i
wouldn't be able to have like this
satisfying career because you're telling
myself but it but it's also the career
that we're in which is like what freaks
me out you're like you're up in front
front and center 24 7. you're like your
career is entertainment right so you're
very outspoken but it's also a lot of
travel and you're like how can i balance
can i find someone that has that well i
think that yeah i would have to find
someone extremely independent that has
their own friends that has their own
life that isn't like a needy little
[ __ ] which they're i've dated many
before and it's like they just like hold
on and like that's not my vibe they're
people that like love being independent
like that's their energy is this guy a
driven person so the guy from hinge like
he ended up being yeah driven and he
works in television which was like okay
okay cool relatable honestly relatable
check check
i'm
yeah he you know the sfk thing kind of
got brought up like he was like like he
was talking about doing due diligence
before day like googling the person to
be honest i didn't even google him i
didn't [ __ ] care like yeah
you don't do the background check like
okay i feel like bad saying this but
like no like i don't either and i don't
either you do yeah i never do it no i
think i should but new york is like very
busy and like i feel like that's what
like he's not gonna bring into an alley
but you maybe but i kind okay he like
went to a school and like
it felt fine yeah and then um but he
said he did um due diligence so it was
kind of like oh yeah would you would you
hear and he was like oh that you have a
card game like my girlfriends love you
they're fair okay so but it was actually
great that it was like the first day
we're like i wasn't embarrassed
he
he totally got it yeah he got your butt
yeah listen he checked a lot of boxes
but ugh what was it
i just don't think i just came back from
vegas where i like you're in love with
the videographer it's just like like
there was a spark that you know
like i think that maybe if he was it was
a spark it was like a connection that
was like
un like
we didn't have that much in common i
mean yes videographer video right right
right so [ __ ] hot but it was just
like there was a connection there was
like an unspoken you know this other guy
it's like everything was textured but
then it was like yeah i didn't want to
[ __ ] his brains but maybe exactly
honestly you can feel it like there is a
difference between someone that you're
like but i think what i'm hearing from
this videographer guy in vegas is that
he left some things for you to figure
out like there was some mystery whereas
this other guy basically came in knowing
everything about you so there's nothing
much left to share yes yes and no like i
mean we did that's what dating is like
getting to know another it was more him
he was just like oh it made me question
like do i want someone that's like very
much in the new york city world that we
go to the same restaurants and same
places and his friend groups in mine
would probably merge really nicely and
like yeah similar upbringing or do i
like the i do i actually want someone
that's more outsider because my parents
were very much outsiders they didn't
grow up in the u.s so
it's like i think that actually maybe
that's maybe why you're attracted to
this other guy but all really good
questions to be asking yourself when
you're going these days it's not
necessarily like oh i didn't like it
it's like why like you think about what
was it like to be honest with you when
he was kissing me i was like a little
like like okay and that's fine no but
you should feel smart i mean i'm not
saying that it's like it should be
knocking off your heels whatever why not
i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
why not beyond it so yeah
i'm saying that
i knew but that's and i did it a lot i
was single for three years and when i
met my current boyfriend i was like this
is so different he was living in new
york i'm in l.a i'm like and i love the
newness of both of them because i don't
know [ __ ] about new york and yeah now no
i don't i'll be back baby i'll be in
acme um but that's the thing and it's
like i think that you just know innately
i think you also know yourself very well
more than like yes there's things you
need to figure out we're all fine-tuning
every single day
but i think in your gutted guts your
body literally naturally responds to
someone that you're like this is your
person and maybe the maybe the
videographer is not your person's
soulmate maybe he is maybe he is
but it also shows you like okay i need
to feel this reaction
not this like this guy could be a friend
like the one another i think women have
really good intuition and gusting to
what they want uh-huh but i also love
that you posted recently i think it was
a reel of things that you were like
absolutely not if he has so let's go the
opposite you put up like a list of i
think one of them was like was it like
flat shoes like yeah can you just like
my [ __ ] nose your [ __ ] nose yeah what
are some of your [ __ ] flat shoes is
for me you know i love a heel uh but
before dating guys well i think like you
know
it's interesting i think sexual
attraction is really important and i
love that yeah that we called you out
because you're like you don't have to
get swept off your feet like i think
that that's the thing i think women
settle that's true like why not like
wait for that really right right i'm
preaching something opposite when i
literally had that experience it's fine
which is fine because i think it's like
we want you you want me to win so you're
like maybe it's okay
i think that a lot of people before this
i was talking my friend they're like
well you just start going after the bad
guy and you just want like the good
guy's too good it's too easy whatever
i'm like yeah
no like i think that we have good gut
and it was not a [ __ ] yes it was a yes
caps but there was no [ __ ] yeah
it was a yes yeah
that was such a great answer right yeah
so and i'm sorry but like don't force it
you know right now
like i feel like also you know he's
really adamant about seeing me again and
i partially i'm like no because i don't
want to waste his time like i already
know but then i'm like well he did want
to take me out to dinner and like that's
nice now you're going okay it'd be nice
but do you not want to want to waste
your time and like go for something that
you're not even going to pursue so
let's let's talk about my situation
because i feel like i'm kind of relating
to all of this completely
that's what i'm here for
basically i
sometimes don't evaluate in the moment
what i really want and then it gets too
far gone and you're like oh [ __ ] now i'm
like way too deep into this
i realize this isn't my person we aren't
that compatible
like
what can i do before to sort of avoid
that because i never really have that
conversation with myself to
say like chasing the wrong thing well
like if there is a red flag i'm not like
that's a [ __ ] no i'm like well that's
that's a
hard maybe okay so wait wait so this is
what i do
i write i start writing down a list ah i
write the list later no no no right you
write it in the moment all the little
things that are like
didn't love that because wouldn't he
like i think that we know we tend to
idealize anyone we're dating like after
the second day i'm like in love and i'm
like [ __ ] i don't even know him yeah
it's like start just like like literally
like you have to train yourself to just
start writing it down and like because
ultimately you want to be with your
person right like even if it might suck
and they're so close like i feel like
the guy from last night i was like he
could he was that maybe like 85 90 maybe
yeah but if he's not 100 no it's all
right it was one date right like i don't
even know him so auntie sorry we're
presenting the best versions of
ourselves right so it's like
something too like you're gonna go on a
date you're gonna turn it on so i think
that but also yes i think writing down
the x writing down the [ __ ] knows
writing down the things that like maybe
are like me yeah it's not a deal breaker
but it don't work give me even like a
second chance if you're like there's
these things that i don't it depends
what the things are okay yeah to be
honest like if it's like he had ugly
shoes like you can fix that you just buy
him new shoes for his birthday we can
fix that you're an amazing what do i do
about
getting over the breakup like moving on
rejection is redirection you're gonna
meet your person and you're gonna be
like oh my god this is why it didn't
work out yeah ultimately if you have to
beg or fight for a relationship it's
never gonna work out right ever ever i
know like if you have to beg and
convince and be like why aren't you
fighting for us bye that's so true
that's what you did was the thing about
the expired milk and it was so genius
like can you can you just literally put
everything it makes it so how do you
remember it like verbatim because i
would love to like say it basically like
you know when a relationship is over
you know it's the equivalent of milk
being expired do you put the milk back
in the fridge and expect it to be fresh
again or do you just toss it and move
the [ __ ] out and buy new milk look like
it's not like he's expired he's done
he's cottage cheese he's like moldy
right now he's it's over almond milk
he's definitely like two percent he's
done oh my god whole thing
yeah no okay
it's done yeah and he's moldy he's not
even milk anymore it's like it's not
even it's done it's just heartburn right
yeah that's actually pretty good yeah
that's pretty good so you know it's like
it's it's better to move on there are
seven billion billion people on this
planet you're gonna find your person
yeah stop wasting your [ __ ] time it's
done it's not it's okay you too yeah
yeah yeah
not even a question not any question
anything a lot of the pressure that we
put on ourselves it comes from media and
like and maybe our friends that are in
relationships and like oh my god like
there's no timeline like even like the
people that seem the happiest could end
up getting divorced in two years yeah
you just never know just focus on your
journey but like once it's broke it's
broken it ain't fixing it yeah it's
expired it's flat and bubbles are gone
i'm like bob the builder trying to fix
all these men but i think really too and
i don't know how to use tools yeah i
mean neither die yeah um
but i think too something that you need
to think about is like how much of this
relationship and the ending and him not
wanting to fight it is the validation
that you need from him versus finding it
from yourself
and i mean you need if you are such a
fan of mine you got it you got to start
talking yourself in the mirror wait i'm
hoping you'll do it a little bit it
needs to be i don't i do it's zero and
so i need to
know each other for two years now and
she hasn't done it once and she quotes
your milk story and you don't like
yourself no honestly i watch your
content and i love it because i could
see such authenticity and like
everything you say is so genuine with
such purpose behind it and i'm like wow
i love it it's so inspiring and then i'm
like i don't know why i don't ever apply
it okay well you're applying it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah like we're gonna
do it like it's it's just like it's it's
it's not that scary yeah wait way harder
[ __ ] in your life that's true yeah
you're chasing too much of like i want
to be in love than saying like i want to
be in love with the right person for me
and that there's a total difference by
myself and that's yeah and that's
yourself first and that's where the
whole thing of i'm gonna just like
downplay what this guy is like oh he has
this but maybe i can just fix him like
no no you're gonna want to find someone
like fall in love with you guys i'm
gonna date myself but i'm telling you
that's when it happens
then you're so happy with your life and
yourself that like whoever comes better
be an eleven out of ten if not it's like
bye like i'm happy i don't need you all
right my friends and my family i've
asked ffk
so ugly
i needed to hear that
i feel like there is no proper timeline
to start dating after you break broken
up with someone yeah
but honestly i feel kind of weird
jumping back to the dating scene and i
would love your advice on how to nail a
first date like what do you wear what do
you order do you order like drinks like
oh absolutely yes what do i wear last
night i wore a blazer hot a bralette and
like pants but advisor was like open so
it's like this is possible
and like yeah yeah yeah oh my god this
is a job interview not a date he
actually said that at one point because
i was like hounding him with questions
oh this is something someone said that
to me too one time i was on a date and i
asked them a lot of questions with their
family life because i'm curious i'm also
doing a slight background check because
i'm trying to get like 23andme and the
guy ended the day going like i thought i
was being interviewed for a job and i
was like this is the job so so i would
actually
commend you for doing that and i
actually saw someone talk about this
recently yeah the first date is that you
you let them you make you get everything
out of that true then the second day
they can ask you anything they want like
get it out find all do the background
check everything like there's a lot to
figure out about someone if you want to
see them on another day um
something else two drinks and ditch
always always two drinks and dutch
people like don't even know
just drinks like
dinner on a first date
how hungry are you oh you see this is la
doesn't do that la is like we should
demand it i'd rather get a coffee than a
full two-hour dinner a coffee with
stress anything anything but our
bailey's in it i can't do it yeah
maybe a hike would be better like or is
that like nothing oh my god you're stuck
me being sweaty
no service and you're stuck
actually like
i would either have dinner for two hours
okay yeah that's interesting um i guess
you should definitely bring the card
game then in case you're like stuffed
i think like you know honestly if you if
it really is that vibe and outline which
i didn't know yeah it's really
interesting to me
i feel like it might be wise to get on
the phone with them beforehand and
facetime them be like can we face
somebody because if not how the [ __ ] are
you going to like sit there as if you
absolutely have no idea
right
right right right um i do i would still
cap it at two drinks yeah i'm sorry i
think so dinner or not
you know like last night he was like i
would have a third and i was like
respectfully no because like i would i
was like how did you approach that do
you actually say respect respectfully no
it's just like i'm waking up tomorrow
really early to work out which was true
and i always book a workout class the
next day super early so smart so it's
like even if i'm having the best time
you leave leave mystery like leave them
wanting more that is
such a smart that is such a hack and
then you never feel guilty about like
making up some crazy story about like a
cat being you know
yeah that's such a good idea yeah always
always the police class that like so
that's
pilates at seven a.m bringing the card
game bring the card and wear a blazing
umbrella where whatever makes you feel
like a boss [ __ ] and batty you know
what i mean without showing too much my
mom says go to your go-to outfit that
makes you feel the best and it does not
always know what mine is exactly but you
always have to go for that because then
you don't even think about how you're
feeling because i know one of the worst
things that we do sometimes is we put on
an outfit and we're like we don't feel
that good yeah and then the whole
[ __ ] night you're thinking about that
outfit yeah and no one gives a [ __ ] what
you're wearing no no they're thinking
about what they're wearing but you're
still stuck in your head so your
personality everything just alludes that
you're not that confident so when you're
going on a date just choose the thing
that makes you feel like this is it like
i'm owning this room even if you're not
but like you don't think you are so it's
good 100 right it's about you feeling
good i
speaking of feeling good you have always
been so vocal about self pleasure self
love and i really really love that
because i think a lot of people are
super hesitant about where to start and
i know that we've we had the girls got
to eat um come on before and they've
always been very vocal they brought us
vibrators it was fun i know it was so
much fun um
so how did you feel like that was
something you wanted to get into because
i know that it's it's something that's
very taboo and which is crazy personal
like yeah a lot of people will be like i
don't want anyone to know what i do in
my bedroom well to be honest with you uh
i started like humping things when i was
like four years old i think we all did i
think every girl yeah every girl did but
didn't really know things right they
were doing it like but it was like a
problem
like your parents were like this no like
it's my teachers were like in preschool
or like we need to talk about your
daughter and they were like what that
was like
she's not she's not staying in between
the line
yeah no i was really obviously like
really in tune with my body from a young
age also really [ __ ] bored because i
was an only child so it was like talking
to myself in the mirror or like
masturbate like there was not much there
was not much like what can i make myself
the best it's like an imaginary friend
it was productive right yeah um but i
think that like when i went to college i
obviously stopped humping surfaces in
like places
was not going to be interesting
quite quickly
in college i like remember talking to my
girlfriends about it and some of them
were like i've never masturbated in my
life or someone's like i've never had an
orgasm and i was like oh my god anything
part of the reason
this was happening or like i have sex
and my boyfriend like has never made me
come and i'm like oh my god like it's
because we're not talking about it right
once you realize like hey it's normal to
have things it's normal to
to to expect to
have pleasure and yeah in a relationship
those are things that like you wouldn't
know unless like you had people telling
you so i was like i need to be that
person right i just like don't think
there's any shame in it there is an
ashamed you know what's crazy is that i
when i got to college feeling good like
my parents never taught me anything i
don't know if your mom was vocal about
it or anything but a lot of people just
don't know where to start or what to
grab or how to do it and then you
realize in college like maybe you'll
have that one friend that just like
figured it out because she was just
really curious or she had girlfriends
that taught her but i know like in any
and i've met so many people like i just
don't know i'm scared to buy that like
little thing like which one do i like
that's so sad i know literally and yeah
because i think like ultimately
self-pleasure is like the ultimate act
of self-love right right you giving
yourself
like pleasure like no one else is giving
it to you right yeah that i think in a
way is like a really like a great
confidence thing as well do you guys get
intimidated the fact that you do that um
that i masturbate i feel like they
better [ __ ] not i feel like they
would love it i mean like or bring it
into the bedroom because i know that
sometimes no yeah i mean if again if
like i know a lot of eliza love it and
the guys that have been like what like
bye like literally why it's like helping
you out you can do less work like you
have a little machine this little robot
i know if you like iphone or something i
know but if something you know sometimes
guys are like i don't i feel emasculated
and it's for them oh
it's so hard to be a guy like why are
you comparing yourself to a robot like
like like when you take the batteries
out yeah and if that's something that
you know you don't feel comfortable
doing until you have a boyfriend then
like that's totally fine as well yeah
but i think it's also like they're even
getting an orgasm from a guy like you
have to communicate what you want what
you like and like i just want to help
women give the tools do that to do that
and i think a lot of it really just has
to do with shame what's like the biggest
question you get about that stuff like
sex and love and self-pleasure like i
just think it's like how do i unlearn
the shame that like maybe my parents
talk yeah if they're religious or
whatever it may be and i'm just like
let's think about what sex is one it
gives you two things pleasure right and
a miracle of life right
who wrote this narrative right making it
this like horrific act especially when
women do it when men do it it's fine but
when women do it it's like their secret
their virgin their pure their is
[ __ ] right right right so i was just
saying like really think about like
where it comes from and what sex is and
how it's really like a love language and
it's the right thing if it's done
conceptually between like two people
right
yeah you're calling it a love language
that's really beautiful that's what it
is well that's my nana and she was like
oh my god i love that your mama's so
cool okay wrap up i really just want to
talk about very quickly your tour yes oh
my gosh okay
first of all
[ __ ] amazing you did a 90-minute set
yeah comedy baby all memorized four
outfit changes
like so sad okay
like
i got coveted honestly and i wrote it in
a week but it was the most productive
i've ever been
sick it was just like i i didn't i was
asymmetric and i was just like we're
doing it like talk about you always have
to take advantage of the time you have
right when you have your time off yeah
and i just like you know i really wrote
about the name of the show's do it for
the pot so i wrote about
basically the show is how to become the
main [ __ ] character of your life and
it's split up into five sections with
all my sfk isms like rejections due to
direction
yes it's a no
being alone doesn't mean being lonely
oh we always say that right yeah um and
etcetera and like all the it all they're
all my stories and it's showing you that
like no matter how embarrassing or
shitty or amazing or anything might be
it's like a part of the story of your
life yeah and if you can like learn to
shift your mind like that yeah it just
becomes super fun did you feel like an
absolute rock star no no no no no no
like what did you do you guys are gonna
die when you see the show like what are
you all coming can you bring me on stage
no a thousand percent we should
absolutely do that and i saw you bring
girls to like talk to themselves on
stage i would like and they would start
to do it
we're not waiting until la for you to
start talking about the american
different first time talking to myself
is on stage i'm like no no but girls
would do that they would start bawling
on stage because you don't realize like
how many people are going through it and
they don't feel that confident and they
don't even realize they don't talk to
themselves right and it's free painless
it's easy every day forever and ever and
everyone do you realize that you're
changing people's lives like do you ever
like remind yourself i just wanted to
become the person that i wish i had when
i was little right right like i had my
mom but like it's your mom like she's
she's gonna love you it's unconditional
i wanted like i didn't have a sister i
didn't have someone being like you got
this and i just became that person so am
i proud yes but i don't feel like i'm
changing people's lives i'm just giving
them the tools so they can change their
own right so let's go buy a mirror
because we're giving it to you so you
can change your life okay mic drop
serena i could literally talk to you for
an hour
epic okay
before we wrap tell everyone your social
medias your tour you can find yes your
card game that's [ __ ] date.com you
guys need it it's gonna be epic like
literally it's gonna change your life we
have let's [ __ ] date let's [ __ ]
[ __ ] let's [ __ ] play
um my my plot my ball
no my tour do it for the plot we're
gonna come to l.a i think in the fall so
obviously you guys are gonna be vip
front row please please you have to
dress up like a main character so yeah
it's cool better start playing this
outfit just show up i'm not black yay i
love you guys so much i'm so proud of
you it's so crazy because from going
from zoom to this i mean you guys are
pros like
you were amazing before but like there's
a confidence that you also have doing
this podcast that is very different i
think that really you've literally had
80 episodes over 80 episodes in between
yours and so yeah
well we were waiting until the moment
that we were like okay this
is a lot that you and it still means so
much to sophie and i today the fact that
you came on our show when it was not
even a show seriously it was
non-existent you took the time and you
gave such good advice and you taught
sophie and i how to be a better
podcaster just the way we learned so
much from you and the fact that we're
here in new york doing it again and
we're your biggest fans i love you both
so much you're literally the sisters i
never had i really do love you so much
and we love her guys
thank you for watching we'll see you
next week
okay bye
[Music]